this isn't new anymore so I'm just going
to jet through a really really quick
okay let's just get the general idea and
then we'll go straight to the formulas
okay general solution okay general right
the whole idea is that usually if you
want specific solutions for trig
functions because they go on forever
you'd have to list them all up right so
the usual limitation you get like from
you tell you ten is that we give you a
domain say go to two pi and then say
we'll just give us some solutions in
there okay but you guys know better than
that you know that they follow a pattern
so a general solution is about taking
advantage of that pattern yeah okay so
I'll start off with 10 if you remember
that was the easiest one because because
if you have something like say Sol 10x
equals one okay so let's put in one
actually should be
if you had a plot like was one in there
right the solution to 10x equals one
will be all of the points of
intersection right so you can see them
there so the first one is 45 degrees PI
over 4 radians and then when you want to
look at the subsequent ones right
because the shape of 10 is so simple it
doesn't go up and down it's just the
same thing over again how do I get the
next solutions from pilot for I do what
I just add PI right because that's the
period so your pine pole and then if I
add PI up at 504 that's and then to get
the next one you have enough 9 pi on 4
and so on
ok so we said the general solution for
10 X is equal to and then we had a
number here any number sir I know he was
one but if we call it say C okay we said
that X was equal to well you start with
the base angle right whatever angle you
work out and then they go pilot for
right it comes from this angle here so
you can say either alpha right where
that's your basic northenr or whatever
or you can say because we know our
inverse trig functions now right you
could say tan inverse of 1 that would do
it I could say 10 inverse of C okay plus
and then you've got subsequent periods
right so it just has to be a whole
number
okay so is this really about yes so
there's 10 but we do cosine what was the
difference okay so instead of say 10 x
equals 1 let's pick something like cos x
equals ha
okay
so what kind of solutions are we getting
but the first one because I think was a
radiance radiance
hi
good yes okay so you can see the first
approach you could take is you can go
from there and just like we did before
with tan right you can go forward a
whole bunch of the period okay just one
lot
so that would be forward to PI so that
would land you on this solution here
right which is adding six trees that'd
be 7 PI 3 and you can do that again if
you buy but you can see we've missed a
solution right not really can I go
forward to PI but I've also got if you
put in 2 pi there you've also got this
solution here which I missed right so
from each log of U 0 2 pi and 4 PI and
so on okay you go forward the base angle
and then you go backwards the base angle
right so I guess this one cube is my
phone
okay so therefore we said if you've got
10 right here plus X is equal to C right
there's a general solution for cosine is
you start from your lots of 2 pi right
so you've got 2 & 5 or 2 Empire doesn't
matter right and if you want to get
forward and backward forward and
backward right I've got my plus ellipse
okay and then you've got your basically
which I guess we could say is cos
inverse of C okay lastly sign okay sure
let's do let's do sine x equals a half
ago
so that will give us a nice easy okay so
next equals 1/2 so this first solution
is I what guys sign articular half easy
one plan six five six okay so again we
can take the same strategy we could go
forward to PI and that'll land us on one
of the solutions right but with this one
again okay with this this one over here
okay so I can't just go to PI even
though that would give you some of
solutions only give me half of them so
how do I get the other half well we
noticed now here if I go at intervals of
PI instead of two pi
yeah right so if you think about zero
and then PI and then this is two pi
this would be three this is what I need
to do is might take my bae sangil
okay and for even lots of pie like zero
PI and 2 pi and 4 PI for even lost I go
forward the base angle so that's why
from zero I go forward from 2 pi looking
forward if I want to keep going for 4 PI
I would go forward and then for odd lots
of pine I have to go backwards same
basic right but you go backwards here
together 5.6 you go backwards here to
get I don't know but you're the idea
right odd lots of time going backwards
so therefore when you got sine X is
equal to a constant okay
we said that well it goes off each of
every single lot of pipe not just the
arc
not just the even ones okay so we
started with in PI but there to take
into account the fact that sometimes
here forwards sometimes go backwards
what do we add next yeah we added this
switching thing right
so that was -1 ^ and again the reason
why this is useful is because when n is
even this week are positive so it takes
you forward and when n is odd this will
become minus 1 so takes you back that's
really kind of cool so forward or
backward the base angle which is this
sine inverse of say ok or